it's been a while since I did a book
recommendation and it's mostly just
because we've been insanely busy with
stories and the show etc we ended up
having a couple extra minutes today so I
do want to give you a recommendation now
this is not the normal type of thing I
would recommend I'm recommending to you
the book the vital question by Nick Lane
I came across this book because it was
recommended by Bill Gates Bill Gates
every once in a while we'll put out a
list of books he's reading Bill Gates
known for reading a lot as is Warren
Buffett as are many of these rich guys
who make an effort to have sort of a
wide educational background and I got
the book the concept of the book is to
sort of explore how life complex life
evolved on earth so it is a book about
evolution in the sense that evolution is
sort of operating in terms of life on
Earth but it's not really a book about
evolution specifically it's actually a
book about whether it's oxygen or energy
or the role that different aspects of
our natural world played in allowing
life to develop on earth as it did so I
heard about the topic and I heard the
recommendation from Bill gays and I
thought fantastic I'm going to get the
book it is endlessly interesting but it
is more rigorous as far as science books
popular science books go I am NOT a
scientist and I clearly never pretend to
be one but this is actually relatively
advanced and I know that there are
people in the audience who are really
advanced in science and they will tell
me David the vital question is lit
written for really lay people and I will
say then I am NOT as well-versed in
science as a lay person because it
actually is pretty we talk about deep
dives this goes really quite deep into
multicellular organisms and eukaryotes
and all of this different stuff
definitely much harder science than I'm
used to but it's been an interesting
experience to just sort of struggle
through it I will look up if I if I
straight up see a term that I don't know
and it's not being defined in the book I
sort of get the impression that I should
just know what that means and I will
look it up and sort of struggle through
it enjoyed it more difficult than I
anticipated but I still highly recommend
it and if you've not been aware of my
recommendations
I recommend everything from books to
documentaries nonfiction and fiction
books websites internet newsletters I've
recommend that all sorts of stuff and
you can find a list at david pakman.com
slash recommendations and by the way you
don't have to do this but if you use the
links at david pakman.com slash
recommendation to make purchases of
anything you see there the show gets a
little bit of a kick back alright so
very very exciting stuff we have a
fantastic program for you today next we
will be taking phone calls there are
lots of people who want to weigh in on
the news of the week the news of the day
we will answer audience questions close
to the end of the show and then we've
got a tremendous bonus show for you
today
how much time are you spending waiting
for the subway in New York City there's
a new initiative for the MTA to actually
sort of quantify the amount of delays
and problems with the subway wish we had
that when I lived in New York City we
also have received some of the first
images from this Russian cannibal couple
there's a Russian couple that are
cannibals were cannibals and it's
absolutely vile and disgusting in every
way and I just hate cannibalism stuff
but we will talk about it a little bit
on the bonus show and also uber
continues having more and more problems
I think one of the first moments where
they started having some PR issues sort
of at the national level beyond just the
fact that their workers really don't get
paid well and our independent
contractors rather than employees was
around the entire travel ban New York
City JFK Airport yellow cab boycott to
call it something that's not
particularly concise that was a major
negative national story for uber and
they've since been kicked out of a
number of cities and now even New York
is evaluating what they want to do with
uber so all of those stories and more on
the bonus show sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership and of
course please follow me on twitter I'm
on Twitter I love getting tweets from
the audience whether they are positive
or negative and as you know most of them
are actually negative but anyway you can
find me on twitter at deep hackman the
show is on twitter at david pakman show